el primer ministro de bélgica considera
que la situación es insostenible más de
3700 personas se encuentran
hospitalizadas por kobe 19 de las cuales
al menos 800 están en cuidados
intensivos el viernes el gobierno
endureció a las restricciones por
tercera semana consecutiva esta vez con
la esperanza de ralentizar la
propagación entre los niños ahora todos
los mayores de 6 años deben usar
mascarillas mientras que las vacaciones
escolares se han adelantado antes
estaban previstas para iniciar en la
víspera de navidad y ahora el 17 de
diciembre pero algunos creen que es un
poco tarde estoy haciendo una pasantía
en un colegio y los alumnos se enferman
todas las semanas es un círculo vicioso
hay que pararlo para mí no tiene mucho
sentido esperar hasta una semana antes
de los festivos se debió haber hecho
mucho antes es muy tarde
en alemania este hospital en bavaria
ofrece una imagen impactante el personal
ilumina de color rojo en las salas de
cuidados intensivos que albergan a los
pacientes con kobe 19 con la esperanza
de advertir a las personas sobre el
empeoramiento de la situación el país
está viendo los niveles más altos de
infecciones con más de 64.000 casos
diarios reportados el sábado entretanto
noruega ha introducido varias
restricciones regionales y nacionales
incluyendo el uso obligatorio de
tapabocas en interiores en oslo
que creo que usar la mascarilla es la
mejor manera de protegerse contra este
virus así que estoy feliz de que la
gente las esté usando de nuevo sin gran
malla a partir del sábado suiza ha
dejado imponer una cuarentena de 10 días
a personas provenientes de países donde
la variante omicron ha sido detectada el
gobierno espera que la movida salve la
temporada de turismo aunque los viajeros
igual tendrán que realizarse una prueba
antes y después de su llegada